foreign
on Twitter has a question actually she
has a couple questions for us yes she
does here's what she says how might we
set kind boundaries with family members
who seem to thrive on drama and Chaos
what about boundaries with family
members we've emotionally and mentally
outgrown especially regarding topics
around sexuality non-traditional
lifestyle choices and religion
so Nedra we obviously get dragged by the
relationships we cling to oh I wish you
would change I wish you would see my
point of view or even worse
I'm gonna make you understand me
and that rarely ever works out what's
the the
um who was Upton Sinclair who said a man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion still right and so yes I
can convince you of something oh but I'm
different I'm going to convince you of
it
yeah but as soon as you turn around as
soon as I turn around you cease being
convinced so for Anastasia you have a a
chapter in your book about boundary
violations about codependency
and in mesh man can we talked to
nastassia about um
well creating those and she was clear
here kind boundaries
maybe sometimes we go out of her way to
be overly kind and maybe that doesn't
set the boundary in a way that is
effective
I think when people have a different
perspective from us we do try to
convince them to think like us and
perhaps it's kind to accept that we
think differently about something and to
not argue about it I know that sounds
like oh that's that sounds like it's so
easy but it's really agreeing to
we think div and you don't even have to
tell the other person they can say
they're one thing and you can just
switch the topic because you already
know that you don't agree on this topic
and there's no changing your perspective
or changing their perspective there are
many things that people talk about that
we may not necessarily agree with and we
don't have to bring them to our side but
that's our that's what we think of is
like okay this was a great conversation
because now they think like me and
sometimes it's accepting people won't
think like us and the kindest thing to
do is allow them to have their thoughts
and I have my thoughts they don't have
to agree with my lifestyle and you know
my political views or whatever those
things are and it's it's okay I I still
love this person I still want to be in
relationship with them and these are the
five topics that we just can't talk
about
I found that with our own podcast here
so me at TK and Ryan we all voted
differently in the last elect
presidential election and it's not that
I think they're wrong or bad and oh man
they'd be better friends if I could just
get them to vote like me see my point of
view right no it's and I think TK is a
bit of a he's a Mozart with respect to
diplomacy he can have the most radical
viewpoint but it comes off as so so
um
normal
it's like a really nice way of saying
you think I'm a French conspiracy theory
no what I what I really respect about
you is that you're able to talk about
these third rail topics in a way that
doesn't feel contentious at all I don't
ever feel like I don't ever feel
attacked by you and even when we
radically disagree about something I
still I still feel supported by you and
how wonderful is that that we can
disagree completely
and yet we can still have a nice hug
afterward and I don't feel insulted at
all yeah I think somewhere along the way
we bought into this idea that to listen
to a person without explicitly stating I
think you're wrong
that that's tantamount to endorsing them
and you even see this a lot in podcast
culture it's very difficult to just let
another person speak if they're saying
something you don't agree with because
we've got a signal to the rest of the
world I don't endorse everything they're
saying that really should just be the
given yeah right that two human beings
sitting down having a conversation is
not the same thing as a concession ahead
of time of everything that might be
possibly said and so there's room to
just let another person say what they
say and say okay
that is that's not the same as saying I
agree I submit to your teachings okay I
got you my brother Gerald who is far
better at this stuff than I could ever
hope to be
he's had a lot of people say to him
things like you ought to do this you
ought to do that and you know he just
kills him every time with like just pray
for me
pray for me
and like you should see like I mean
because people just come at it with so
much heat and he says just pray for me
and it's like there's no way to go for
that it's like oh okay what am I gonna
do with that okay I guess I'll I'll pray
for you right and he may totally
disagree with that person but he doesn't
need to spell out for them I think
you're misguided in order to retain the
freedom that he has to go make his own
choices and sometimes that need to argue
that need to defend ourselves that need
to justify it's it's an expression of
the fact that we haven't made peace with
what we really feel what we really think
and so we feel like we need the
permission of other people's endorsement
in order to have the power to live the
lives that we want to live but we don't
we need validation we're looking for
validation for our perspective our way
of being we're looking for that
confirmation like no what you're doing
it's it's okay I agree with everything
and you're right there are times where
you know if you're confident in your
life choices you're confident in the way
that you think about things
they can have their perspective and you
can listen and you can say okay yeah
pray for me or hmm I like to say
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free